the magic of being like a screenwriter
or any of these sort of like crafts is
to figure out the pattern and then once
you understand it
then figure out how to like bury it so
that no one's paying any attention to it
logan what can you tell someone that's
never written a screenplay but loves
film and television
about the craft of screenwriting
i think obviously
it goes without saying
that you
have to read
scripts
like i
i don't know how you would approach it
otherwise
um
i feel like actually
reading them
and then trying to figure out
like
through whatever means like are
available to you whether that's reading
uh books
or just sort of like trying to like take
things apart yourself like
how do you reverse engineer to figure
out why this
works
right
and
the hard thing with that
is that there's a lot of things
scripts are doing
simultaneously
right you have to figure out why it
works from a pacing perspective and a
plot for perspective and a character
perspective and you know
in theme and emotional arcs and all
those sort of things
um
but i think that the best way to do that
is to read scripts
and then try to reverse engineer them
um
and again like there's a lot of there's
a lot of great like material where
people have done that like you know
robert mckee and i forget who wrote save
the cat i know i have not read save the
cat but i definitely read story
um when i was younger
uh the only other thing that i would say
about it is
don't don't
don't think that any one
like way is the only way
i i think it's important to to sort of
uh immerse yourself in a bunch of
different
uh people's perspectives
um
and then i feel like by doing that
you'll actually start to understand
why it's working
i think that
emulating
is important is an important part of
learning right even literally like
children learn
at the very beginning by just copying
right like they're just emulating what
someone else is doing they don't
understand why
um
that's important but i think to really
sort of transcend that
you need to figure out
why it's working and you have to
understand it on a much
more sort of like
uh intrinsic level of like
again i i always hate to be too
mathematical about it but so much of it
is why
why this line here
why this beat here
what was planted when and why does it
pay off here
and okay sure
that was all done just from a thematic
like place but are there different ways
that you can infuse that
to like you know from a character
perspective or like
again whatever that like sort of means
because all these
different attributes are all sort of
again happening
in parallel
um
but i do feel like that's what's really
important is
again immersing yourself both in the raw
material
like scripts and like movies oh and all
like literally like sorry i'm just like
having thoughts i'm doing this sometimes
if there's a type of movie that like
i'm interested in sort of like figuring
out like why it works um in certain ways
i'll literally like
i will both read the script and then i
will watch the actual movie and then i
will like time out the movie and i will
see
like when like
i will see what in the script how many
like
how many scenes and where they were and
what was happening in them and then all
like i'll put that against the actual
finished movie and then i'll say like oh
okay
because sometimes when someone writes
the script that isn't what ended up
working the best in the movie
right and sometimes you need to like
look at the final holistic project to go
like oh okay like
this is the they made these decisions
that even the writer themselves were not
like
thinking about but like
but if you watch enough material and you
read enough material you'll find you
should find the patterns
i
i think that the literally the again the
magicians like the magic of being like a
screenwriter or any of these sort of
like crafts is to figure out the pattern
and then once you understand it
then figure out how to like bury it so
that no one's paying any attention to it
right
that's not fun for anyone
people want
people want the experience to be new and
fresh and interesting
but even the stuff that is new and fresh
and interesting if you really sort of
start digging in you'll find it's the
similar building blocks you know
um
that's what i would say so when you see
something that you you resonate with you
want to really dissect why did this work
for me and then you want to like look at
the script and then time it with the
actual maybe even have the sound down at
times just to see some of the pacing and
and things like that because to you
that's like a magical product how did it
become magical like that yeah it's just
really like to me it really is reverse
engineering it's like if i walk into a
building it's it's amazing that the ac
is running
if without seeing the blueprints i'm not
going to underst i'm not going to
understand
like
why the ac is running or how it's
running or why they why did they place
it here
because i'm just lost
i'm just lost in the experience of it
right but all those
there's thousands of decisions um
that are made as to why and however you
start being able to figure out on your
own like
how to get to those answers
i think is really like important and
again to me
the best way to do that is to just look
at a lot of blueprints
and to really like dive as deep into
them as you can and then again
looking at
what
people who are experts say
and like understanding why they said the
things they said and then also take it
with a grain of salt because like
there's uh
they're also not the end-all be-all
it's important to like
it's important to be able to like listen
to everyone and take it all in
and realize why they're saying it and
then figure out
how you want to like implement that
right
it's that balance
you have to respect
like
the experts at it but you also have to
then figure out how to take what they're
doing and try to put your own unique
spin on it
what's the wrong way to start
screenwriting the wrong way to start
screenwriting the only thing that i will
i don't know
i don't know the wrong way to start
screenwriting i if i'm
i do feel that like
there's no real wrong way to be
creative right
like
and that's different for everyone um and
it should be
i think that to me
the only thing i would advise
is
to be
to be conscientious of your time
because you can play around with
something forever
and maybe that's all you want to do
um but i think that
i think that the more tools you can have
to try to like
stay on track while still like giving
yourself freedom to play
i think that's the best like um
the best sort of like meeting of the
worlds
and i will also say
that
i do think that it is also important
to be aware that it is a business
and that like
and to have fun and to be creative and
play but also be aware
for yourself that if you're writing
something that's not uh
that's not there's not a market for
maybe there will be but there's also a
good possibility that there won't be
and you have to make peace with that
and if that's like and if that's cool
with you then that's fine like again
that's that's you and your time
um but
like
but if you really
if you're really trying to figure out
how to transition into a like into a
career
that's something that i i would say i
wouldn't
i would not pay attention to that
i think a lot of times
people don't pay attention to things
that like they find discouraging or
uncomfortable
um
or negative
you need
my you need my suggestion would be
to really look at it in
like
in like the eyes
like
acknowledge it you it's it's it's r it's
like it's the difference between like
what some what something is and like
what you want it to be
right
you can even look something in the eyes
of what it is and go like i don't love
what that is
like i'd like to change it i'd like to
it for it to evolve and become better
that's all fine but i would still i
would still start by like going
but this is what i'm up against this is
what people are like looking for this is
what's expected this is all
what the landscape really is what that
information is even if you don't like it
even if it's scary or it makes you feel
bad
you're not going to figure out ways to
approach it
like
and work with it or around it or however
you want to do it if you don't
know what it is
um
[Music]
from my from my perspective anyway
um
when you were working on it takes three
were there times in your head where
you're like i'm not sure if
someone's going to like it how well it
will be received and then how much time
am i going to spend with it
were you questioning yourself to at that
time because you were still
sort of you know it was if you said you
were working on it in a few months
the
in that situation um
to me like to me the next sort of like
step always is
is once i've come to terms with that i'm
going to undertake a project whatever
that is
like
then i
then i fall in love with it
there's no point in
unless something's really not working
right and that's a different story
but otherwise i'm i'm i wish i knew
there's a very famous quote about this
but it's basically like some version of
like you do everything you can to
prepare and then you just go
like and that's kind of i at least again
for me i find that that's what's always
been
uh how i make decisions is i do i do the
most ground work i can to feel as
confident and good about something as
like i can and then i don't worry about
that anymore
and then i just focus on
being creative and doing the best job
that i can
because otherwise
you're
you're just second guessing yourself for
no point you've made
you've made an informed decision stick
with your informed decision
and then if it fails or or it doesn't uh
get what you were expecting out of it to
me i to me
outside of again that first sort of like
uh thesis film
everything i've done that's been like
that hasn't gotten me what i expected or
would have liked to have gotten out of
it i don't have any regrets about
because i believed in it and i still
believe in it
i think that sometimes that doesn't
matter like there's so many other
factors
at play you try to make the best
informed decision of you that you can
about why you're undertaking a project
um
and then
you basically you just give it your all
and you don't worry about whether or not
it will
be successful or it'll do what you were
expecting it to do
because you should feel confident in it
even if external forces
don't line up in a certain way that gets
the result that you want
because sometimes that happens and
that's not your fault and it has nothing
to do with the project
and
and so that's why i think that
i try to approach it that way
you